Bienvenidos a la presentación de graficando líneas,
empecemos.
digamos que tengo la ecuación,
"y"
igual
a 2
"x"
más
esto nos está dando una relación
entre "x" y "y",
por ejemplo,
cuando "x" es igual a 1
"y" es igual
a 2 por 1 más 1
"y" a ser igual a 3
por lo que para cada "x",
en la que podamos pensar,
tendremos una "y" que le corresponde,
así que hagamos eso,
si dijéramos que...
haré una tabla aquí
"x"
"y"
hay que escribir unos
números al azar para "x"
Si "x" fuera digamos -1
entonces "y" sería 2 veces -1
que es -2 más 1, sería
-1
si "x" fuera 0
es fácil
vamos a ver
2 por 0 es 0 más 1
es 1
Si "x" fuera 1
"y" sería 2 por 1,
que es 2 más 1
que da, 3
Si "x" fuera 2
y creo ya tienen la idea de esto,
"y" sería 5
y podríamos seguir porque hay un
número infinito de "x" que podríamos usar
y por ende un valor infinito de "y"
pueden ver que en esta pequeña tabla
se muestran las relaciones entre "x" y "y".
Lo que podemos hacer ahora es, de hecho graficar
esos puntos en los ejes coordenados
entonces déjame ver si puedo dibujar este...
algo
de una manera limpia
estos son mis ejes
Bien,
deja dibujó algunas divisiones a los ejes,
Entonces este es 1,
2,
3,
éste es -1,
-2,
y -3,
éste es mi eje "x"
y aquí tenemos
1,
2,
3,
y por acá es -1,
-2,
-3,
éste es el eje "y"
Entonces grafiquemos
cada uno de los puntos.
Si tenemos el punto donde
"x" es -1 y "y" es -1,
así que "x"...
y vamos a ir a lo largo del eje "x"
tenemos que "x" es igual a -1
y "y" es igual a -1
así que este punto está justo aquí
Este es el punto -1, -1.
Hagamos otro
utilizando un color distinto.
Digamos que tenemos el punto 0, 1
entonces si "x" es 0
que es aquí
y "y" es 1
así que, este punto está justo aquí,
hagamos uno más,
tenemos al punto 1, 3
1, 3
"x" es 1
y tenemos que "y" es 3
entonces el punto estaría justo aquí
y podemos seguir graficando
pero creo que se alcanza a ver,
que estos puntos,
están formando una línea,
déjame dibujarla.
La línea se ve algo como esto.
La línea atraviesa a todos estos puntos,
de hecho el punto
2, 5 estaría por acá arriba
y cada punto para cada "x"
en la que puedas pensar
si tienes que "x" es igual a, no sé,
3 billones 380
la "y" correspondiente
también estará en esta línea
así que esta línea continúa Infinitamente.
Eso representa todas las posibles combinaciones
de "x" y "y" que van a satisfacer esta ecuación,
y por supuesto que "x" no tiene que ser
necesariamente números enteros
"x" que puede ser,
"x" puede ser pi
es decir
3.14159
que estaría por aquí
y "y" sería 2pi más 1
así que todo valor de "x"
tiene su valor de "y" correspondiente.
Hagamos otro
Si tengo la ecuación
"y"
es igual a "-3x" más
Entonces, este es mi eje "x",
y este es mi eje "y"
Déjame poner unos valores aquí
"x" y "y"
Entonces si "x" es
-1
-1 por -3
es 3 más 5
si "x" es 0
entonces "y" es 5
ese es muy fácil
si "x" es 1
-3 más 5 es 2
Si "x" es 2
2 por -3 es -6 más 5
"y" menos 1
y ahora grafiquemos los puntos
cuando "x" es menos 1,
y sólo lo haré de manera aproximada
cuando "x" es -1
"y" es 8 positivo
el punto estaría por aquí
y hay todo un módulo
en graficar coordenadas
si es que encuentran graficar
el plano coordenado un poco confuso.
Cuando "x" es 0
"y" es 5
y estaría por aquí
cuando "x" es 1,
"y" es 2
así que está acá
cuando "x" es 2 "y" es -1
pueden ver que
y
yo le aproximé,
pero si lo hubiera hecho en papel milimétrico,
podrían ver que la línea atraviesa
perfectamente a todos los puntos,
cada punto que satisface esta ecuación
cae sobre esta línea
y algo interesante de esto,
que me gustaría resaltar
es que la pendiente de la línea
es descendente
va de la izquierda arriba,
a la derecha abajo
mientras que la línea que dibujamos antes,
iba de la izquierda abajo,
a la derecha arriba,
hay algo en esta ecuación
que se ve un poco diferente a la anterior.
Les daré una pista
este número el 3 negativo
Podemos decir que es el coeficiente de "x"
éste determina si la pendiente aumenta
o si disminuye,
te dice también
que tan empinada está la línea
y aquí
-3 es la pendiente por lo que...
y haré otro módulo de solo la pendiente pero...
este número de aquí,
es llamado ordenada al origen
y ésta,
te dice dónde va a interpretar la línea al eje
y en este caso se interseco en 0,5.
Hagamos uno más,
vamos a hacerlo rápido
"y"
es igual
a 1/2
de "x"
más
Entonces hagamos nuestra tabla,
"x"
y "y"
y solo necesitamos dos puntos
para graficar una línea
entonces digamos que "x" es igual a 0
eso es fácil
"y" es igual a
y si "x" es igual a 2
entonces "y" es igual a 3
grafiquemos
antes habíamos evaluado 3 ó 4 puntos
pero eso sólo fue
para que lo entendieran mejor
pero solo necesitamos dos puntos para una línea
así que es 0,1, 2,
está aquí y 2 ,3 está aquí ,
de tal manera que la línea
se va a ver algo así
Notemos aquí,
que otra vez tenemos una pendiente ascendente,
y esto es porque 1/2 es positivo
pero no nos estamos moviendo
tan rápido que cuando teníamos "2x"
"y" igual a "2x" se inclina algo así,
incrementa mucho, mucho, mucho más rápido.
en este último ejemplo,
la ordenada al origen está en 0, 2
está justo aquí
así que si alguna vez quieres graficar una línea
es muy sencillo,
solo tienes que evaluar dos puntos
en el siguiente módulo les mostraré un poco más sobre pendientes y sobre la ordenada al origen
por lo que ya no tendrán que utilizar esto,
pero creo que de esta manera pudieron sentir
intuitivamente en lo que es
la gráfica de una línea.
Espero se hayan divertido.